this is a company that came under attack
it Carl Carl Icahn going after them
saying he really wanted to see a split
up of ebay and paypal because he thought
that paypal really was the future and
that had you know such a tremendous
amount of technology that could really
be leveraged so that's CEO having to you
know live through all of that all of
those issues and he do you think that
that might have contributed in any way
to the departure absolutely i will check
gives a given marcus a terrific leader
down at PayPal has really grown that
busy to know when ebay acquired paypal
there's a lot of talk of the guys
invented paypal at PayPal and they're
giving a lot of credit for the success
of that platform but in fact weren't
even acquired paypal it was losing tons
of money losing basically two dollars
for every dollar of revenue which is
actually hard to do they were losing so
much money but ebay in a lot of ways
sought as competitive they didn't want
amazon and someone else to get ahold of
paypal because paypal's as re based
customers were using it so much david
marcus really helped to transform that
business into a very profitable and yet
still a very rapidly growing business
and there's been a lot of people urging
not before and since Carl Icahn urging
ebay to spin that business often to let
David Marcus run that business he's seen
as a terrific leader in Silicon Valley
also raises a lot of money for charity
and injustice I think generally well
life guy down there a very smart guy and
interesting to see him leave because
this is what I you know Corey one of the
points that he had been making all along
with it was very hard to attract and
retain the best talent at ebay in part
because you weren't able to offer stock
options that would have the kind of
appreciation say of a Facebook for
example and he cited the one your stock
chart which really showed that the stock
can basically gone nowhere so you wonder
I mean you know if you wanna if you want
to retain and attract the best talent
you know what what is your stock price
need to be doing to keep them all and
and I guess there are a lot of questions
here as to why he left but that may be
one of them well look fundamentally the
particular in this low interest rate
environment growth is what gets a stock
going and it's Steven
top-line growth revenue growth which to
me as a value guy seems ridiculous but
it is in fact true that companies that
are growing top-line really fast right
now are getting some great rich
valuations and because the top line of
PayPal is growing terrifically by the
way the bottom line isn't bad either
much better than even the very
successful eBay business I think that
really what karl was looking at wasn't
some genius technological understanding
but really just the different kind of
evaluations the market is putting on on
fast top-line growth and good topline
growth of what eBay has separate from
paypal and I think that on some level
David Marcus is going from a company
with really good topline growth to
spectacular top-line growth in in
facebook and you had a company that's
also got a lot of profits so I think
there's a real shocker though I don't
think anyone saw this coming